there's also this massive football
festival going on maybe you've heard
about it's called the nfl draft
experience they've thought of everything
for fans to have the experience of
players of taking all those skills tests
and strength and speed it's really a
cool environment there and apparently
it's been really popular kirsten joyce
now checking it out for all of us
brian and denise day one by far is by
far the most well attended at the nfl
draft experience but we are still seeing
crowds and droves come out for day two
like the folks behind me here at the
gallery taking their photos with all
those sparkly helmets representing all
32 teams another big draw today a flag
football game with former qb's matt
hasselbeck and michael vick families say
it's the perfect trip so far
they've come from across the country to
support their team the hawks green bay
descending upon las vegas for day two of
the 2022 nfl draft experience
as long as i can remember
growing up my dad loved the cowboys and
so it was just something that we did the
naughton family of five of arizona
planned to be here in 2020 when vegas
was supposed to host the nfl draft well
i actually attended a draft in nashville
in 2019 as part of a work event and i
kept thinking the boys would really love
it but the pandemic caused to go virtual
that year giving the family a little
more time to plan this is our first
family trip yeah yeah
yeah yeah everything going good so far
it's great it's been amazing and save up
for the big outing this is our first
time
it's it's pretty crazy here the kids
loving it trying out all the interactive
exhibits like the 40 yard dash
did pretty good honestly yeah
the experience goes until 9 pm tonight
and opens back up bright and early for
the third and final day at 8 a.m
tomorrow reporting live kirsten joyce
live local now we'll send it back to
brian and denise